hello everybody and welcome to part 5 of
let's play nightmare house - we are in a
vent and there is a body charred boiled
body we just got into the third whoa
hello
the third vent of the washing machine
someone's are knocking oh this isn't
where we left off what am i doing I'm so
silly left off just after we got dropped
out of here sorry about that folks I'm
just so stupid sometimes
okay who's who wants some who wants some
Oh anybody in here nope I was ready for
him with my axe oh oh this looks like it
was painful whatever happened I don't
laugh at me what was that crying I
couldn't quite tell oh really
of course it doesn't work I'll bring it
on come on
well there we go all year we let my
battery recharge for a second I don't
know how that recharges I just like
shake it real hard you know wait oh that
was scary
not all right um nothing else of value
seven Oh completely dark hey got dumb
who did that who just bitch-slapped me
nice touch but what the hell are these
okay all right thank you by the door and
one over Josh good enough
all right you used by the looks of it
yeah give me the fuse another
and over there
see here
I know
these look like identical panels so I
would assume they come on
oh I see
remove these dead ones I saw a third one
over on the floor over there get in
there and the other one alright there we
are
yeah ready oh good chunk is that your
industries again nope I don't care what
company that is they suck
ah okay
perfect timing for my wife oh [ __ ] you
oh that's how you want to play it huh oh
I'm Way too manly for that to work on me
as you could tell by my battle cry
out in your year
oh there we go oh so pretty alright hi
for you oh fast are you yeah oh you're
armored huh not armored enough for this
I'll get up Oh Killian riot so pro so
dodge oh you suck gon take Oh
security gate opening please stand clear
yeah that's right watch out everybody
markiplier in the house hecka direction
they'll open
don't look at me like that judgment
stare hi not bitch-slapping me I don't
appreciate it not cool man
and now my are you slap this [ __ ] out of
my flashlight great phenomenal hi mom
Oh can't see whoa aah get out of here
get out of here
dead man this must suck for you guys cuz
you can't see a thing I can't see a
thing
man all right glad to get out of there
Oh was this another Skellington Oh Oh
scary
that's a little better I guess I got to
go down there hey don't do that look
pretty to do Skoosh
all right oh no it's a trash compactor
nope
good thing I don't have an r2 unit Oh
climbing up okay I'm trying to help you
guys see but I can't see a damn thing in
here just follow the sound of my voice
just come this way towards the line
which is about to go out all right
pitchblack time OOP oh oh oh good all
right moving on
gets in my way yeah they're up almost
there what did I jump down if I'm just
going to climb back up oh to do that
okay
ah there is a reason Oh get your
revolver
oh yeah making slow progress but steady
well I haven't had a jump-scare in
another minute better line one up this
game sure does like the jumpscares
atmosphere is good too don't you know
it's a good atmosphere oh but the
prologue we like just all jump scares
let's splish splash oh hey oh dude you
all right oh that is Seager Nugent and
douching uh-huh
hardly scary yeah your showers
people don't get up get ahead trust you
on this one oh you got up you okay he
was smart enough to not get up and you
were not so fu fu man f you all right oh
it's bright oh thank goodness finally
sleep right hey oh no nothing lights I
just said it was bright damn it
ah fu all right
trying to help you guys out by keeping
it steady in the light one place Oh
who's in there all closing the door cuz
you're so scared of me I understand that
perfectly understandable
oh hey all right Wow tell mething with
that give me don't be fiddling with me
[ __ ] slapping my [ __ ] slapping me not
my flashlight and then messing with my
flashlight who do you think you are
Hey oh hi my flashlight uh okay all
right
whoa ah Billy you there Billy
whoa what the hi I see you I see you go
away can't even shoot okay that is
creepy
I will admit very creepy
oh let it go dude delegate Ghoulie boo
boo ha ha ho yeah that's what I'm
talking about oh oh hey oh hey whoa oh
wow okay all right all right I'm tougher
than this hi who's there who wants some
oh you and and you wait how many are you
what hurry you first
I'll trust you oh there we go
okay Hey Oh
boo-yan I'll boring who's there I see
something Oh who's there what the hell
are you doing
ha all right man this mod does not stop
that beepings hearing in the way
oh of course I gotta go in the vent a
pitch-black vent oh boy oh no oh no oh
no oh no oh no oh no oh no my qu oh man
I knew it was coming
oh I knew it was coming Oh still freak
me out okay alright probably not out of
the woods yet oh man
huh alright okay
Oh No
what the oh no oh it's messing with me
oh it's totally jerking me around
oh no not not again oh man how are they
doing this oh no not again
oh god it's getting shorter all the
rooms getting shorter okay I got to be
facing that direction for it to work oh
boy oh no oh no oh no oh now I'm in the
trash compactor Oh No
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy ah [ __ ] you
god damn it
uh huh oh man oh I got goose bumps after
that one oh all right well I gotta cut
it here well thanks so much for watching
that's the end of the game so I hope you
enjoyed that either half good I'm tough
I'm tough I'm so tough ah I will see you
guys in part 6 of let's play nightmare
house - bye bye